what I'd like to do today is really take
a pre Braun look at data from
riot of different viewpoints I want to
provide some additional background
material and then I'm going to look at
some basic practices that can be
employed to improve the quality of data
management this will be largely geared
towards students and so on and then I'm
going to use three science examples two
of which will be used to identify some
key principles that we can employ to
help scale up a lot of our work to much
broader scales and some of the data
underlying data management activities
that under underpin that and then the
third science example that I will
present will be largely focused on how
we implement this and it will get into a
lot more of the education details let's
start off with a little bit of
background material in the sense that we
I think in this room probably all
recognize we are undergoing a major
change in paradigms with respect to how
we think about and deal with data and
this is the past view or this is
certainly the the linear approach that
more or less was followed as I was going
through school and up until not too too
distant in the past but the changing
paradigm is this the recognition that
data products are a valuable result of
the scientific enterprise and these data
products need to be retained preserved
and then reused and that's what we see
via this particular animation and it is
there there are four major drivers I
think for this paradigm shift that we're
seeing the first one deals with science
and throughout all of the various
funding agencies and all the work that I
think most of us are involved in we
recognize that the challenges we face
both scientifically and societally are
very difficult
and they require working across many
different disciplines so the director of
the National Science Foundation for
example is focused on what she calls
convergence or convergent science this
is really recognizing the fact that in
order to address a lot of today's
scientific and societal challenges we
need to work across different
disciplines and scientific domains in
this case this is a report from the
National Academy that focuses on the
integration of life sciences physical
sciences engineering and so on and this
is really will be apparent in at least a
couple of the science examples as I
present shortly I use in SF but I think
again a lot of other agencies and a lot
of our research efforts are looking
again at some very complex issues the
graphic on the right illustrates the ten
big ideas that NSF is decided to focus
on over the next several years or
possibly a couple of decades and you can
see again in the lower left growing
converging research and NSF but then all
the other research ideas at the top are
ones that clearly cannot be addressed by
working in a single discipline you know
you have to work across different
domains in order to adjust a lot of
these issues work in the Arctic and
Antarctic for example requires a whole
broad array of different sciences and
engineering the second driver I think
it's what we're seeing through societies
and publishers one of the first examples
that I was aware of and actually
participated in was a 2011 meeting of a
whole array of professional societies
and publishers that focused on
developing a joint data archiving policy
and this started out with maybe a dozen
15 ecological environmental biodiversity
biological sciences and societies that
got together and said you know we really
need to make sure that the data are
retained
and support the publications that come
out of our particular societies or
journals and since that initial 2011
declaration I think about 300 journals
and societies have signed on to this
joint data archiving policy other larger
commercial and other journals plots and
nature science have also essentially
signed on to the same argument that you
know when we publish a paper the data
products need to also be made available
and interpretable as well the third and
clearly a big driver for those of us
that receive research funding from
virtually any agency now or private
foundation is the the recognition that
all of these sponsors require that the
data be made available sometimes with
maybe a short embargo but the bottom
line is that you know unless it's
personally identifiable information it
really should be open and accessible
within a very reasonable time frame
after the date have been collected or
after the articles have been published
and again this goes international
scishow both NSF in the u.s. NIH has
similar requirements and then all the
various private foundations that I'm
aware of including Wellcome Trust in UK
have a similar requirements and that's
something that really I put this slide
together before this past weeks release
of the newest Climate Assessment but I
think this also points to recognition
that decision-makers the public and
others want to see that there are data
underlying various statements that are
made in the scientific literature and so
on and essentially you know evidence
driven decision making is where we are
heading very rapidly the climate this
was the previous climate in a national
climate impact
assessment and this was again at the
time it was recognized that they that
the folks that the scientists that were
involved in this needed to also provide
access to the data and this was sort of
done after the fact all of the scripts
and initial scripts and so on were
retained from the analytical work but
there was many many dozens of person
years that went into providing the links
from the text in the impact assessment
back to the data and the algorithms that
were used so this was not automated and
again there was a massive team that was
put together to again provide this
direct linkage between the science and
the underlying data associated with the
graphics and other analyses that were
performed so that leads me to something
I'll touch upon periodically throughout
the remainder of the talk and that is
the research data lifecycle and I show
three here the one up on the upper left
even though I'm a library and it's a
little bit difficult for me to figure it
out it's quite complex and I know all
the people that developed it originally
and and so on but and then the second
one comes from American Geophysical
Union and it mixes a little bit of the
research lifecycle with the data
lifecycle and then the one on the right
is one that I on my colleagues with data
one created many years ago and this was
designed to help us organize educational
materials best practices and then
pointers to various software tools and
services and we felt that this kind of
an approach that's despite the arrows
pointing one way it's really not linear
and I don't think I
show various alterations of this but it
is possible to for example in a
monitoring type project to go through a
planning phase and then up through a
description and preserve and then that
might be more or less where you stop for
the time being other studies that are
really synthetic or modeling and
character might start with the discovery
phase where you're discovering existing
data you're doing integration across
many different types of data sets and
then you perform the analysis and
visualization based upon that so again
it can be a nonlinear process but again
the point being that these are all
phases that I think are resonate pretty
well with most people as they think
about their various steps in their
research activities and I think you can
read all those so I won't go through
those the other thing again the point
for pulling this together initially was
to really think about what are some of
the best practices for managing data
throughout the lifecycle and what are
some of the best tools that are out
there and this just shows a real tiny
subset of some of the tools and services
that are available most of them focus on
open source tools you know for a lot of
the work that we do in nowadays are and
some of the various services and tools
associated with it are really quite
effective and I know 20 years ago if I
were to ask this room how many people
were proficient in our you know guess
about how many hands would go up maybe
two or three out of a room this size but
and I'm not going to ask you today
because I don't want to be proven wrong
but I would guess that if I ask today
you'll probably about half of you have
some proficiency with with our in the
audience so again this shows the entire
lifecycle I'm not going to go through
each of these but I will point to I'll
be coming back to this using some of the
science examples to point to some of the
various tools that I think are important
that you
be aware of and these again many of the
principles I'll be focused on all relate
back to this research data lifecycle so
again I wanted to relate things back to
some real science here so I chose three
examples I'm going to start off with two
but all the magazine covers here really
demonstrate the the the significant
challenges that we're experiencing and
having to deal with these days from both
scientific and societal standpoint the
two that I wanted to start off with deal
with Ebola that's the one in the upper
right circle and then challenges to
Earth's biodiversity is illustrated by
the National Geographic cover in the
center I started about initially
thinking that you know there probably is
some very different messages I could
draw from each one but the more I looked
at the two efforts a lot of the
principles that came out of both of
these scientific activities were very
very similar so I'm going to focus on
some of the biodiversity examples but
again I think they apply very equally to
health issues as well and if I'm wrong
I'm sure I'll get some comments during
the Q&A session so this is um the reason
I do focus on the Ebola is this is a new
effort that I've been involved in just
the last couple years through the
International Science Council and codata
and there's a big interest in
internationally in terms of figuring out
ways to deal with some of these
challenging data issues that work across
different domains and then how do we
make data much more interoperable how do
we take some of the existing data that
have been collected and then
use that to make mitigation strategies
much more efficient monitoring much more
efficient and so on as well so with
Ebola and other vector-borne diseases
the point of this graphic is to show
that really understanding these
vector-borne diseases and developing
mitigation approaches again requires
working across many different scientific
disciplines and domains so you can see
on the right here we have biology of the
agents involved population genetics
water supplies sanitary engineering
transit travel one transport a whole
array of things that really relate to
the spread of these different vector
borne diseases so it is non-trivial and
then you get into the treatment phase
you know how do you efficiently treat
some of these diseases or try and
staunch something like Ebola from
spreading further then it gets into a
lot of the human dimension and medical
dimension as well so that said we have
been able and these are some of my
colleagues that have been working on
this we have been able to look at the
spread of diseases like this and then
predict predict risk factors for spread
to other areas of a particular region so
this work was again done with respect to
the Ebola epidemic that hit Western
Africa and there was a lot of a lot of
the existing information made it
possible to then go back and really
model it and in depth largely looking at
things like travel time and distances
from one area to another so a lot of
this is more or less geographically
driven and we can certainly do that with
the existing data but we start looking
at some of the
treatment strategies or how to deal with
a major outbreak and then the whole
swath of different agencies
organizations countries get involved
particularly with something like Ebola
that is affecting numerous countries in
a region of the world so this just shows
a really a tiny fraction of the various
agencies and organizations that were
involved in responding to the West
African Ebola outbreak you know it was
great that all of these organizations
stepped up to the plate and brought all
their forces to bear but what happened
afterwards this is what we see you know
all the data that were collected and
associated with understanding and
treating the outbreak they all went back
to those individual respective
organizations and we now have immense
difficulties in accessing the data or
even discovering it and then secondly
because all these different agencies had
their own various idiosyncratic
approaches for managing the data the
data were all captured in different
forms column headings were different you
know databases were different some were
in proprietary formats others were in
Excel spreadsheets others were you know
a whole array of different almost every
imaginable solution that could be
employed was employed by these different
agencies and for some reason I'm on Otto
Excel here but this points to some of
the challenges again that we discovered
through this activity through codata and
international Science Council then this
is a 10-year project to really work on
ways to streamline this so that the next
key bola outbreaks are much easier to
understand and then also to
so here were some of the initial
findings from essentially doing data
inventory data audit for all the various
data sources that contributed to that
initial understanding and treatment of
that Ebola outbreak and you can see the
results here but again all the data were
largely remain isolated now on different
silos they had their own domain specific
formats but Cabul areas ontology x' and
I'll talk a little bit more about some
of that in just a minute and then again
they were on different types of formats
as you see here so again I'm going to
save some of the principles learned from
this until I conclude this second
example because I think they are very
close to related but this is looking at
quote the fragile earth biodiversity and
this shows from G Beth and this is
probably actually approaching or
exceeded a billion species occurrence
records now that are available through
GBA if this was a screenshot from a
month or so ago so I'm sure it's larger
now and you can see again where a lot of
the biodiversity work has been done over
the years largely in the US Europe and
then Australia New Zealand this
particular graphic though shows all of
the various sources of biodiversity data
on the bottom here and you may not be
able to see all this but it ranges from
individual specimens genetic material
citizen science observations is
indicated by the binoculars photographs
there's a whole array of now sources for
biodiversity data and then the uses are
really quite varied this relates to
conservation needs for sure food
provision food security health a whole
array of abuses for
diversity information and the challenges
in the past in terms of actually getting
of the biodiversity information and then
transforming it into a useful format for
research and decision making has been
again pretty immense challenge so this
has led to a fairly recent concept that
we create what is known as essential
biodiversity variables and the approach
here and hopefully you can see it better
than I can from this angle but is
essentially to collect and process some
of the raw by diversity and specimen
data and then package it in a
standardized format so in the center
here is a key a key component of the EBV
framework it's create a data cube that
has space-time and then the other axis
is either species or ecosystem function
or some other key parameters that we
wish to delve more deeply into and the
whole idea is again to to focus the
community on developing these products
that are much more standardized well
formatted and documented that can be
reused for a variety of different
purposes it would be easier to integrate
let's say data from one data cube with
another data cube and then address some
of these complex challenges and then the
bottom here basically points leads to
essentially the area on the right here
which is assessments reports other key
decision documents and one of the
reasons for generating this format in
the first place was to help identify
whether or not nations in the world were
meeting their biodiversity targets and
other sustainability goals for the
United Nations
so that's all theoretical over the last
couple years my colleagues at both the
global biodiversity informatics facility
and the Atlas of living Australia did in
uh three different pilot studies looking
at the feasibility of developing these
data cubes showed previously and they
work with three three species in
particular the first one is an acacia
it's a tree that is native to some parts
of Australia but it's become invasive in
other parts of Australia the wasp is
European wasp that is truly an invasive
species in Australia and the third is an
Ibis species that is also invasive but
the potential impact is is relatively
unknown on ecological processes and
function in the ecosystems there so
there were a number of challenges in
association with this and the the first
goal was to really take the data that
were available through G Biff and then
also take the data that were available
through the as lists of living Australia
recognizing that they each were tapping
into different museum collections and
sources for the data so there would be
clearly the first couple of challenges I
show here were anticipated there will be
some under lapping coverage from let's
say ala 2 GB F and then in some cases
they'll be tapping the same sources
there would be duplication of Records so
in order to get to create a nice clean
data set you had to be able to deal with
both of these issues in particularly the
deduplication of Records is somewhat
non-trivial export mechanisms differed
between the two packages so again what
you want to pull data out of gif it's a
very different approach than pulling it
out of Alice of low noise
raelia and even very simple things that
you should think you would think that
had been agreed upon column headings its
long we're all entirely different
between the two different systems second
another key challenge was the fact that
there were no mechanism for logging the
processes so when you perform various
activities through one of these cyber
infrastructure organizations there was
no way to track what you had done so it
was all essentially a manual process and
then lastly there was no single tool
that was effective for manipulating the
data and that was one of the reasons for
having to export all the data and then
manually more or less manually integrate
data from the two different
infrastructures and then Lee bellman who
friend a colleague of mine he had I
think something that has probably common
to a lot of any efforts that we in the
audience have participated in where
we're trying to integrate data we
initially think it's an easy thing to do
but then if you read this comment
there's like many more steps were
required then even the most pessimistic
player could envisage and I think this
is something that we've all experienced
so this led both the initial formulation
of EBV zazz these as a data product or a
new framework for collecting and
managing biodiversity data and related
types of data and then the challenges
that emerged from these three pilot
studies that I just showed led to a
group getting together in Bari Italy to
develop a framework for to establish
principles that would make it easier to
essentially create these essential
biodiversity variables and again I think
the the principles that came out of this
apply equally to
virtually any other effort including the
Ebola example that I showed earlier as
well so I'm going to step through these
principles and I'm going to dive a
little bit more deeply into the first
one here because I think it's it's
really quite relevant today and this is
the the first one that again you can
sort of take out where it says e Vivi's
but just apply it to virtually any study
but in this case it's important to have
a comprehensive data management plan and
then I'll point this to a paper that are
published in PLoS computational biology
in 2015 it's in the ten simple rules
series and those of you that know Phil
Bourne formula with NIH he created this
series and plus computational biology
it's called ten simple rules and that's
ten simple rules for just about anything
we do as scientists so if you want to
would hope that at some point he's going
to compile all of these but if you want
to you know identify the ten simple
rules for writing a research paper or
ten civil rules for creating a really
effective poster presentation or you
know there are now probably 60 or 70 of
these ten simple rules papers in the
series and it's a great place to find
again useful guidelines for doing just
about anything we do as scientists or
researchers so this one is one that I am
going to delve a little bit more deeply
into and you can see the research
lifecycle at the very top this is maybe
someone abbreviated but I think it
should resonate with folks fairly well
and then the data lifecycle is just a
slight variation of the data one
lifecycle that I showed previously but
it's got a lot of the same components so
again I have ten principles I'm going to
show but now I'm going to shift gears a
little bit
and go into creating a data management
plan I'm going to provide these ten
simple rules and then we'll get back to
the principles after I do that so
hopefully this makes sense so the first
one is to determine research sponsor
requirements and this is very important
one of the reasons I say this is you it
may not be so and obvious when you
actually let go and look at NSF for
example and try and figure out what the
sponsor requires because you have to
delve a little bit deeper there more
deeply in the sense that NSF is a single
agency is has the unusual perspective
that every different Directorate and
many different programs are so unique
that they each require their own
separate format for data management
plans so you have to identify which one
is relevant to the particular program
that you're applying to but virtually
every agency now has requirements for
data management plans and some of these
are spelled out in some cases it's
beneficial to actually talk to a program
officer and determine what the specific
requirements are secondly identify the
data to be collected the types sources
volume formats and so on and things that
are really critical in this case I maker
volume and then type and a lot of people
overlook this they you know if it
becomes evident to reviewer that you are
collecting massive amount of data let's
say terabyte of data and you plan to
analyze it be an Excel spreadsheet then
you're probably a little bit naive with
respect to the research you're about to
do also format is important if you're
working with geospatial data again
that's something that you would not ever
want to tackle and a spreadsheet format
probably but you would probably want to
use a geographic information system or
some other more appropriate tool and it
similarly was something that requires a
lot of transactional or
a database database management system
might be much more appropriate the third
rule
define how the data will be organized
some of this is apparent from my
comments with respect to the last rule
and then fourth explain how the data
will be documented and this is again not
it necessarily is trivial as we all
might like in many cases that's useful
to contact researchers in the field talk
to a research data librarian for example
to help identify the particular metadata
format that you should be using and and
then also identify particular tools
there are a lot of metadata formats out
there some of them don't necessarily
have user-friendly tools associated with
them that allow you to create and manage
the metadata at least as easily as we
would all like the fifth is to describe
how the data quality will be assured and
interestingly at least from my
perspective this is something where we
sort of gotten off the the right the
right Road over the last couple of
decades or so I know when I went through
school which I know it was in the dark
ages but we were all required to take
statistics and as part of that you know
there was usually a section on terms of
how to manage data so
Quality Assurance quality control was
really you know impressed upon me from
the very beginning but now I see lots
and lots of students and even
researchers that don't really think
about the data quality side of it until
they end up with some results that are
really quite apparently erroneous in
some way shape or form and then they go
back and try and figure out well what's
wrong with the data because the data
aren't supporting what I think they
should support clearly not the most
appropriate way to be doing
but this gets into things like you know
the data entry side of it you know in
some cases that brings in some engineers
to the table in terms of making sure
that we're actually automating the
capture of that data correctly from in
the field sensors and otherwise and then
how we deal with manual data entry and
then they're in a plethora of really
nice and usable tools out there that we
can use for QA QC again many of them
available through our and packages that
are developed in the our language so a
lot of these are free and open so I
would encourage you to check those out
rule number six present a sound that
data storage and preservation strategy
and there are a number of questions to
ask here you know how long should the
data and be available I know John Folse
a database specialist at the University
of Virginia asked me at a meeting about
35 years ago I remember him saying one
of the challenges that all of you
environmental scientists face is you
don't know when to throw away data you
know you just assume that you're going
to keep all these data forever and in
reality it's not feasible
probably nor desirable to do so you know
we continue to bleed lots and lots of
data simply because we have no way to
really capture and maintain those data
for the long term but in those cases
where we do have valuable data sets and
we can say it would be nice to retain
these for 10 20 years then we need a
place to do that and there is a site re3
data org it's the registry of research
data repositories any of you that are
interested in identifying particular
data that might meet your needs this is
a great site to go to it's also a great
place to go to to determine where the
repositories are that you might want to
deposit your data
after you are during or after you've
completed your research project the next
phase is to define the project's data
policies and clearly I and agencies
encourage more openness in this regard
so something like Creative Commons CC 0
or CC by license is highly recommended
and then relate describe how the data
will be disseminated will it be simply
available through maybe a data
repository for those that are lucky
enough to discover it or will you take
the next step in terms of trying to
publish the data as quote a data paper
which you can more easily do now through
a number of sources as I show here and
then the last couple rules are one
assigned rules and responsibilities
identify those people in your lab and
others that will be taking on different
components of this and then prepare
realistic budgets so that those
reviewers will be able to see that you
know yes they plan to do this particular
data management activity and there are
real dollars to support it the hardware
software personnel time or otherwise and
it's a great tool that will help step
you through this
it's the DNP tool dot-org those of you
that are not familiar with it check it
out it's free easy to use now this gets
back to the principles again and I'm
going to go through these probably just
fairly quickly so again with respect to
the work for the essential biodiversity
variables anyway and again I think it
applies more broadly is to identify a
common framework of dimensions and
conform with established representations
for data formats and so on and this is
where a lot of communities the focus
significant effort in terms of
identifying preferred standards and
again instead of creating your own
adding on yet another standard to the
thousands of standards that are
exist she's something that has already
been wildly adopted within your
particular community third products
should have human and machine readable
metadata again compliant with community
standards and some of the community
standards I show here are out there and
in many cases there are some reasonably
user-friendly tools that will help you
comply with these different metadata
content standards the fourth is all
products should include information that
helps assure the quality of the data and
I show some examples here again from
some fairly simple approaches scatter
plots on the left are really a great way
to get a sense in terms of the data
distributions help determine whether
your data are normal or need some kind
of a transformation and then an
important one here that a lot of
experimental or people working with long
records of Institute since they're
collected data for example use or these
quality control charts and all of these
are well the ones on the left and one on
the right and many other qa/qc
visualizations are easily done in our
and there are a number of textbooks that
will help step you through that and in
the center I show one that I've not been
able to figure out how to do an are yet
but there probably is a package there
but this is a quality control chart
generated through JMP which is often
available what many universities that
are very reasonable discount v and i'm
gonna go into detail here but this is
more for the programmers and the
audience is to use standardized
application program programming
interfaces or api's and again the idea
is to just make it easier to integrate
across different organizations by
following
are using common api's so I will take a
little bit of a departure here and look
at data one for just a minute a project
that I'm involved in and this is how we
do that we have a common API that we
provide to the different data
repositories that we're working with we
have about 40 some data repositories
that are all part of this Federation and
the idea was to create a single portal
where a researcher could identify the
environmental data they were interested
in working with again very easily
through a common single interface and
this is what it looks like basically go
to data 1u there are lots of ways to get
to this particular screen and you can
see a variety of different data sets on
the left this is looking at the entire
set of data right now just looking at
one area of the world but we have global
coverage and you can see virtually
ourselves got many many data sets
associated with it and the different
logos that were there on the left are
the different repositories that hold
those data and then we can look go it's
a via faceted search and again this is
all enabled by having in that common
underlying API and we can go and look
let's say for data within a specific set
of years or particularly loquacious or
maybe a specific tax on or other ways to
learn really drill down and identify
this very specific data that we might be
looking for the sixth is to use standard
workflows and then have these fully
documented and published and this was
the challenge that lee Belvin ran into
with trying to pull data out from Dallas
of living Australia and G Biff and that
there were there was no real way to
automate that process or track it so
some solutions that are out there and
they're more than a probably a couple
dozen really good workflow package
is out there in different areas some
really good ones in the bioinformatics
arena that some of you are probably
familiar with to that that I'm most
familiar with our Kepler which was
developed out of Berkeley initially and
then secondly Taverna which was
developing the UK but has now been
adopted by the patchy organization so
these are all workflows that again
capture can be used to capture all the
different steps in everything from data
acquisition through manipulation
massaging the data to creating
particular analyses or visualizations
and all of these are captured in these
workflows and then it makes it possible
to either rerun those workflows or
what's often done is to take these
workflows and modify them may be added
in extra data or revised the the data
that are contributing to it or add some
new visualization to the workflow as
well and then publish that new workflow
as a separate entity with its own
individual identifier the package the
site in the center is called my
experiment and this is a location where
a lot of these different workflows can
be published so this is a again a great
side if you want to see if anyone has
done a particular complex analysis and
if so you can look at their workflows
and then potentially rerun those connect
up with the individual researcher and so
on so the seventh is provenance
information should be readable both by
humans and machines this is a real
challenge
currently there are not a lot of
provenance tools out there there's a lot
of work that is how I did through the
sign on the left that I highlight open
provenance org and then also in data one
org our group we have started working on
this and we now provide some tools that
support generation of provenance
information for two particular packages
one is MATLAB and then the other is R so
it is possible to generate provenance
information for those two packages in
our environment and then the other
relates to ontology zat again I'll get
into a great detail here but there this
is the way to help make sure that we are
being very precise with our definitions
and relationships across concepts OBO
foundry is a great site to look for
these and then lastly I show env oh the
environment ontology is one that we use
pretty extensively in the environmental
sciences the again data should be
preserved in a community repository I
mentioned re three-date org earlier but
there's a nice way to search through and
identify particular repositories that
might meet your needs
and then lastly data should be timely
open and fair and fair is a common
buzzword these days that stands for
findable accessible interoperable and
reusable and there's a great site that
will help you identify tools and
services to help make your data fair and
this is the open fair sharing org site
and there's information there for
example to find metadata editors and so
on that will help you out with different
steps along the way so the third example
I'm gonna conclude with is looking at
our filthy C's here and this was started
from an effort by been helping and
others at the National Center for
ecological analysis and synthesis
looking at trying to understand the
health of our oceans and what leads to
that current state so this was an effort
in 2008 that was published in science
and clearly as we would expect a lot of
the health of our issue oceans and
coastal areas are related to traffic of
shipping and so on bringing an evasive
species exotic species to different
ports and so
this effort led to the recognition that
this would be a great thing to
understand but to repeat on a yearly
basis to see if we are making any
efforts or progress with respect to
improving the health of our oceans so
this led to something called the ocean
health index and this started up in 2012
and it continues through present and
basically what if you go to the website
and if you just look up ocean health
index you'll be able to find it very
easily
it covers roughly 250 areas of the ocean
economic zone coastal economic zones and
then open bodies of water on the planet
and you can go to any one of these
individual areas and look at the health
of that particular area for maybe a 10
10 or 12 different themes here so things
like ability to support fisheries and a
whole array of others that are all part
of this ocean health index all data that
are publicly available and collected and
updated on a frequent basis so one of
the the values in going to this site
though is looking at some of the work
that they did so in order to replicate
this from one year to the next
they developed a toolbox to help support
this and then a lot of their work was
published in this paper here in Nature
ecology and evolution this is Julie
Lowndes and colleagues from the ocean
health index project this paper is again
directly available through the the
website and it shows what they did so
they developed their framework the
scientific framework that led to a
specific toolbox that was used to again
generate this ocean health index for all
of these 250 plus or minus areas on an
annual basis and the important thing I
wanted to illustrate here is in the
right which is this is the ease of
collaboration
with respect to creating this annual
ocean health index and then the ease of
reproducibility is on the Left axis and
the point being that they started out in
2012 with a great deal of science a huge
amount of effort that went into creating
that framework and developing that
initial toolbox and then in 2013 year
two it took a lot less effort to
actually reproduce the calculation of
these ocean health indices and then the
rate will progressively spend less than
less time on the informatics side of it
and more and more time on the research
side of it but with an overall reduction
in effort over the course of time
hopefully this makes sense so you can go
to the ocean health and I index and dive
a little bit more deeply into it they
provide all the tools and so on but
again a key point is there are some of
the resources that were used and then
they have an introduction to open data
science that is very easy to go through
to provide you know training in terms of
how to replicate this sort of work it's
a great source for learning about again
some of the key tools and approaches and
you may or may not be able to see it I
can't read it from here myself but I
think in the middle portion on the left
side is a key statement about one of
their approaches was in terms of doing
this was to form a small community so
this working group through NCS formed a
small community and essentially helped
work themselves through all the various
tools and approaches for creating these
ocean health indices using open science
tools so they all sort of got in the
same room and they learned our and our
open science and a number of the tools
together as a group so I want to
conclude I think with this slide or
maybe the next one with some other
sources of information
jiseop the Earth Science Information
partnership provides now a clearinghouse
for information on a whole variety of
different informatics topics so if you
want to get training in any particular
area it's a great source in the upper
right shows data one org we have ten
modules that cover all the different
aspects of the data lifecycle so we have
lots of education resources there our
studio provides lots of online learning
for different aspects of our programming
language and associated tools and then
something that you know you may want to
consider here we've just are doing this
through the University Library and at
New Mexico now but we are entering into
a partnership with the software
carpentry x' to run data carpentry
software carpentry and library carpentry
on a frequent basis at our University
and then as well as around the state
recognized that we need more people that
are much better trained in programming
skills data management skills and so on
and in a lot of cases I would argue they
are not getting that through traditional
computer science programs and I think I
stopped here and can take questions as
time allows thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you always need someone to get us
started so you lay out a clear set of
activities I could go on to improve our
data management how do you see the split
between the institutional
responsibilities around those processes
and the individual research activities
or researchers responsibilities but some
of these say oh you know you need a
repository and put it here and do that
and individual researchers don't have
that so do you have you given do you
have a position on sort of how to find
that balance or what that looks like
across the fields you've hit the nail on
the head there that's a really tough nut
to crack in the sense that you know I
look at agencies for example on funding
agencies and you know they have these
mandates as I've showed respect to
making data available one they point
their finger to individual scientists
and institutions for meeting those then
when I talk to the institutions they
point to either the individual
researchers or the funding agencies as
being responsible for various pieces in
part so again there's no real clear
consensus but what I think is really
reasonable is you know within an
institution to you know look and see
where you're going to get the greatest
efficiency the greatest big bang for the
buck so to speak and I would argue that
what a lot of university not a lot some
universities are starting to do is
provide research data services and I
know we do this at UNM I think Purdue
does this as well and that is to provide
research librarians essentially data
librarians out to different colleges and
they serve serve on the front line in
terms of working with faculty and
students pointing them to how
to get their data into some kind of an
institutional repository be it their
University or non University repository
how to create data management plans
using TMP tool you know there's a lot of
things that could be done through a
centralized service like that that said
it's also incumbent upon individual
scientists to know their
responsibilities with respect to the
data production side of it as well so
the the thing that I find really quite
shocking is the extent to which most
sponsored research offices are not
cognizant of the compliance issues that
they are facing I was recently on a
panel with a rep a lawyer from the
Office of Inspector General and the
National Science Foundation who was on
his way to quote potentially shut down a
University's research program because
they were not providing access to the
data that were collected so you know if
you're having us that funding and H
funding others you know you are really
supposed to provide the data the
university is responsible for that and
that means that a student for example
the collects data off of a sponsor to
grant if they don't leave the data and
make it available when they leave then
the university faces a serious
compliance issue so again there's not
been a whole lot of examples made but I
guarantee you sometime within the next
couple of years NIH NSF other private
foundations are going to step in and
they're going to start making examples
so it's probably beneficial for all of
us in the room particularly librarians
sponsored program offices and so on to
really think through this and ascertain
you know which organizations within our
university our best poised to help
researchers with this particular aspect
of the data management
cycle
so as we're waiting for another Oh
having a question man
do that the presentation
yes yeah I'm happy to provide that I did
trying to include as many of the links
to various other resources and salons
please check those out and if you
identify others that I might have
overlooked I'm always welcome for
feedback as well so oh is worth waiting
on oh if there's any other questions but
again to get back to yours one of the
things I think we can all play a role in
and that is an education either self
education through some of the sources
that I showed there or you know
establishing carpentry classes and a
cadre of trainers at our various
universities installing instilling new
courses I know a number of universities
I've visited lately they have short
seminars and workshops available through
the University Library which oftentimes
has chosen because it's a centralized
location it's objective it's easy for
people to find it and then there might
be short work or short workshops on you
know how to create a data management
plan or how to use are for this
particular purpose and so long
so you've been talking about a lot of
across institutional projects with
managing and making research data
available what kind of I guess like
legalese needed to exist behind the
scenes like so that there was
understanding you know people's time in
various institutions but also so that
you know for the longevity of various
projects that you know somebody's not
going to pull out at the last at the
last minute and so that there's some
institutional support going forward for
those kinds of projects right that's um
again another great question this gets
into the people factor and the I think
it's there are two things one is in some
cases you do need like written documents
to support this where you're trying to
get agreement across border activities
so again like the Ebola was a great
example there that was really
challenging it's still a challenge in
terms of getting all those various
organizations that I showed that we're
working in West Africa to agree to share
their data and it's been non-trivial and
all of them have individual requirements
for dealing with confidential issues and
so on so that was like maybe a
worst-case scenario but there have been
some agreements that have come out of
that it's I think it's called the Sendai
framework that is helping drive a lot of
this so it's a UN framework in other
cases when for example the collaboration
with ala and G Biff this was done on the
basis of personal communication you know
the fact that Lee Belden and his team
knew the people at Chiba and they were
quite willing to work with one another
and had a history in fact of doing so so
some of those easy quick successes or
you know a great way to sort of open the
door there but it is a huge challenge
Paul Euler is work with the National
Academy as their data guy for three or
four decades now just recently retired
but he is consultant but he said you
know this is still probably the biggest
challenge that we all face is like you
know legal aspect of interoperability so
the technical issues can be solved we
know that there's still work to be done
clearly but the legal and social
interoperability aspects are still
somewhat the most challenging and we
part of that can be accomplished through
education I mean simply getting people
to recognize that you know there really
is no need to try and carry your data
into your grave with you you know it's
probably more valuable to share it and
provide it as a product the key thing is
to that we all want to see is that those
people are generating intellectual
products get credit for it so and
there's a lot of effort right now
through data one and the data site and
other organizations to provide credit
for those data products so if you
generate a data product and publish
let's say in a repository like Dryad
there's a digital object identifier
associated with that and you can
actually add that data product to your
CV just like you can the article that's
associated with the the data products so
that's some that we should all be
working towards as well it's really
getting people to adopt that I will ask
one question of you all how many of you
because this is important with respect
to this particular topic how many of you
have orchids
so okay if you don't know what it is you
probably don't have it so orchid is and
is a unique identifier for you as a
researcher so if you're generating
papers or products and you want them
associated with you so for example Dale
Hendrickson here you know if he wants to
get credit for that product that he
created and not have it associated with
Dale Hendrickson back there because it's
a common name there's like multiple Dale
Henrickson's then you know he would have
an orchid ID so this is really critical
and then I'm you know go ahead and jump
on the bandwagon now because a lot of
agencies are going to be requiring this
universities are going to be requiring
it but it's again a great way to start
getting credit for your intellectual
output and that's our CID for those of
you that are trying to look it up so
it's misspelled
well now that you've mentioned orchid
ideas I'll ask a question about them so
there seems to be two aspects of
understanding things with research and
data and things one is who did it right
who deserves the credit and then who has
current rights to it how does that play
out across this and how are those
distinct and what's what's happening
with that and how do you see that
evolving the so a number of the metadata
management systems or metadata tools
that are out there for creating metadata
provide fields that are used to identify
that so you can as specify who the
originator was possibly who created the
metadata and then possibly who the
contact is for using the data so one of
the things I encourage is people to
document data and always shapes and
forms as comprehensively as possible so
you know if there are steps that need to
be taken to use the data or you can
provide additional information then do
that as part of the metadata that's
probably the only way in the long term
to you know ensure that at least there's
a high probability that people would use
the data appropriately that you know the
citation will be done appropriately for
the originators and so on and that is to
include in the metadata that's
associated with the data so that's the
only solution I'm aware of
hi I have a question about
reproducibility so you mentioned
Providence and some of the tools that
are available in are in MATLAB to record
the process what is your assessment of
how these developments like this how
they've been accepted by publishers and
what's the relationship between
publications and the underlying
processes that led to the results that's
a tough one in the sense that the there
are a number of tools that are now
available publishers have initially
taken the view by and large that it's
the data products themselves that should
be available they've not really taken
that next step and even a lot of funders
have not taking that next step and
assuring that the work flows you know
you know the scripts are scripts and so
on that are you know generated
particular data products are available
as well so that is a bit more of a
challenge it ultimately it's up well
it's up to two to groups you know one
funders at some point are going to start
enforcing this so and I've seen this in
a couple cases where people have been
funded for you know long projects and
they put in a renewal proposal and then
the panel will look and see whether or
not the data products are available from
that first set of funding and if they're
not and they'll recommend or decline to
the funder which they can either accept
or not and then secondly it's up to
publishers and others to again have as
part of their peer review process the
fact that people can go and look at
those data products as well as
underlying scripts so very few journal
editors do
it requires more work on their part to
do so I'm an editor for ecological
archives and we do require that we
generate these golden oldie ecology
datasets and we want to make sure that
the data product has been the data
itself has been reviewed as well as the
metadata and then we also require the
submission of the if there are any
particular scripts that were necessary
to transform that those be available to
reviewers as well but until we take that
next step then you know a lot of the
workflow tools and so on that can
expedite this are not going to be fully
embraced it's all part of the training
as well in the sense that you know the
first time you create a Kepler workflow
is you know it takes a little bit of
work you know it's like when I show with
the ocean health index toolbox you know
that that group of researchers they had
to get together and strain themselves
because they didn't have carpentry and
other mechanisms for learning these
tools so they sort of did themselves but
there are now education ways to figure
out you know how to create and use these
workflows ultimately I think it comes
back to the funders as well in the sense
that they are going to have to put a lot
more funding into creating more
user-friendly software tools and
services you know what I've got a lot of
my funding out of the size that NSF and
I feel like I can criticize them now in
the sense that you know it's easy to go
in there with an idea and get funding to
create like let's say a prototype but
then if you want to take that prototype
to the next level and make it really
user-friendly and intuitive so that you
know anyone can come in and reuse that
tool then that's where the funding falls
short they typically don't take that
last mile so to speak and that's what's
going to be really critical as we move
forward
so in the social sciences especially in
political science there's a movement of
some of the journals to make acceptance
for publication contingent on
reproduction of the results and so you
submit a manuscript and you also submit
all the materials that went into your
analysis and here at Yale we shameless
plug but there's a group of us who have
developed a workflow tool to help in
that process and that we're calling it a
curation process really because we're
parenting the data the code that are
going to become public to make sure that
it really reproduces the results and so
there it seems to be more activity on
that front but I agree with you that the
publishers have to require it and then
the funders really need to put some
dollars behind it - yeah it weird this
big transition period now and I would
argue that you know we really do need to
see this major transformation occur and
part of it is in let's say tenure and
promotion practices as well it takes
more effort to do a publication and then
provide the data product with good
documentation and all the workflows and
so on they're associated with that so
someone could reproduce you know or that
set of analyses if necessary then it
does to create let's say five
publications without paying attention to
the data and and so on and what we've
done is we've created this beast I think
in academia where you know you know your
livelihood depends upon the number of
pubs you know and you want to spend as
many time generating eight or ten
publications that year as opposed to two
or three there are really high-quality
publications plus high quality data
products that are associated with that
and until we start changing some of that
mindset it's it's going to be a little
bit difficult so agents funding agencies
and professional societies and
publishers are all going to have to
again get on the wagon train so to speak
and move in this direction and
personally I would like to see fewer
publications anyway because I can't keep
up with them anymore it's like let's
reduce the number it's just a little bit
of self-promotion for Yale bill
mentioned the orchid unique identifier
Yale has access to that service and if
you need help with that reach out to a
research data librarian or a librarian
across the system they can help you with
that
another tool he mentioned it's the data
management planning tool we also have
that at Yale and anybody can use that
and a real shortcut to get a lot of this
is there's a website called research
data call one word led you and all that
information is there great
[Applause]
[Music]